[Music]
in inspiring transformation news
submitted by PD says hi JK hey I want to
name a dog PD good name a couples
transformation photo after kicking their
drug addiction goes viral really I want
to see a transformation where it's a
couple where it's a boyfriend and a
girlfriend but the girlfriend turned
into a boyfriend and then the boyfriend
turned into a girlfriend but they still
love each other which one wear the white
dress which one wear the tux I don't
know the girl the second one
it's a 2020 2020 relationship 2020 2025
it would be no y address where we can
find another old it was gonna be a blue
and mm-hmm
wait what's this about I just flipped my
[ __ ] mind
Brent and funny cuz I'm with you the
math couple so this was when they were
meth heads after all thinking the
opposite really all they did was change
the [ __ ] they don't know different
that has changed the lighting that girl
just dyed her hair and put glasses on
the ones on the left look like if you
left your garage door open they'll be
sneaking around but the ones on the
right they look like they teach like a
subject to your children I don't know
about you but I'd rather hang out with
they're more fun they look like a more
fun-loving people these people like I
get out of my house they look like after
they've recovered
I enjoy why people on drugs they seem
more relaxed nah have you seen meth
heads on drugs
oh no not never mind never mind but they
don't look like messy though they look
more like I like to drink and smoke some
weed and relax to some reggae so Brent
posted on his facebook with that photo
of the first photo I just showed you and
he captioned it hashtag clean challenge
this is my wife and I an active meth
addiction
the first photo was taken around
December 2016
the second one was taken in July of 2019
this December 31st will be three years
we have been clean and sober and living
for God I hope that my transformation
can encourage an addict out there
somewhere it's possible to recover okay
what do you think you want to talk and
cookie and I'm saying what am I supposed
to be [ __ ] why is this viral all
about though is you know I don't like
religion but if it gets people off the
drugs good good for you
I like religion for that reason yeah
well if you can keep people out of my
backyard stealing my [ __ ] lawn mower
or something so they can buy some meth
awesome awesome let's just let them join
a cult I don't go [ __ ] it join
Scientology I don't go [ __ ] just get
them off the drugs and many depends
would you rather have a couple on meth
or a couple become Catholic treason oh
[ __ ] well as long as they're not
stealing from me or my kids and I became
the blinky guy meme yeah wow yeah I
don't know
Brad was saying that he struggled with
addiction he began on he was nine years
old and started whoa meth no no
cigarettes my daddy beat me by twelve
using marijuana drinking and three years
later he tried acid and other drugs but
one night when tragic night ten years
ago he and his brother Jess who was 19
they were partying together they were
both got really drunk the brother asked
him for a ride home but then he said no
because he has to sleep before work he
has to rush home and sleep before work
so when he woke up the next day he found
out that his brother drove home and was
in a fatal car crash and that's when he
just went hard with the meth he was
selling Ashley weed and that's how they
met and after two years of friendship
they began an on-again off-again
relationship where they used meth
together and that's when he ended up
going to jail so he served two two years
out of a 10-year prison sentence and
when he was released in 2016 he met up
with Ashley and they celebrated his
release by using meth
yeah and so it sounds like a barky and
he barely passed his drug test and so he
was really scared like he was gonna be
sent back to prison so he just told her
like let's just get high one last time
and never touch it again and that's what
he did
Wow oh they just went cold turkey how do
you barely pass a drug test and I think
he can't either pass refer yeah
reading I mean I was thinking the same
thing - maybe the level was like here's
like not passing and they were like pee
pee pee pee pee I would think that if
like anything above zero they detected
some matter maybe there's like
secondhand secondhand levels secondhand
meth are okay I don't know like my uncle
was smoking another room there was a
mean the thing about a couple that
smokes meth is like if you're together
for a year you're really kind of
together for two years if you don't
sleep you know I mean so usually you
really need to know somebody we don't
sleep and you talk a lot yeah so
connected has such a healthy
relationship great yeah so then they're
saying that stinks over the first year
was super hard but then they they helped
each other so like if one of them had a
bad day in one and like was craving and
the other one would come in and like
talk them out of it vice versa what if
when they're on meth the room and house
was so clean and organized but then once
they got off of it now the house is
really dirty cuz they don't have and
they're like OCD yeah they're not the
motivation to clean anything anymore
yeah so it might be it might be good to
go back sometimes I think yeah I think
you're right why doesn't that make you
want to clean monthly almost you ever
lose energy and you're like I don't know
where to put it even if it's just in
spring just for sprinkling pretty well
healthy healthy mouth actually I bet you
they rearrange our furniture like every
[ __ ] day when they're all bad they're
not supposed to like any any like like
addiction recovery type so you're not
supposed to be in a relationship
whatsoever yeah that's that you're not
supposed to support each other cuz more
often than not you bring each other yeah
come on be in this book one last time
that's why I'm surprised that they were
able to both be addicted and quit
together
viral yeah cuz in most cases man like
you're supposed to get away from that
life and oh they did
that they they cut off ties with
everyone else who did that's [ __ ] cute
now yeah and then so they ended up
finding a church and that's when like
their new friends at church really help
them through it - yeah so you're you're
saying like oh cool have a cookie but
they actually did have a lot of you a
lot of cookies said why this is viral
this is not like that doesn't this
happen or don't people get off meth all
the time yeah I think so it was really
inspiring for a lot of people and in it
ended up how am I being a downer
nah oh I think cuz you're a rounded man
like or we're around it so we've seen
people come on and off of it and all
that but there's people out there that
are not around addicts or drugs and then
or or those people that are still on
drugs they might see this story and be
like oh [ __ ] man I can I can actually
get off actually of trying to say that
or commenting that they inspiring a lot
of people is an advertisement the church
paid for like see you come to our church
I think they were Methodists that's tie
your right up [ __ ] Mickey's oh no
what you trying to do is that now you
know you know what you know I think that
I feel like I'm really hating on this
inspirational story but I think what it
really made me hate on it was the fact
that the photo like I was ready for like
a good transformation photos oh yeah
it's just the lighting is different like
I could go take a picture in a dark
alley like this cuz I was picturing
sneagle turned into Tom Cruise yeah a
little bit it looks like he's having a
great time you just look like he's
really [ __ ] high so then right here
they're just you did put on some weight
after he quit math though yeah he's
starting to eat a hamburger happy wait
happy wait dude speak you know
drug-testing though my cousin went to
work for this like really big company I
won't say the company's name but they
did drug testing by taking one of your
hairs and then they test that and they
can see if you did drugs like eight
years ago or however long your hair is
which i think is kind of discrimination
because people that like buzz their hair
like they cut it short and you can't
tell but if like you did meth like five
years ago and you're you have long hair
that looks like a fossil record yeah
it's a long time not for you yeah good
but you're saying that your hair yeah
like this end is like from when I was
like in my 20s though right so there's
probably guys probably got some Molly in
it like Cabernet in it oh the hardest
drug that I've never heard of that
before
yeah 20 years ago my mom drug tested me
in high school how did you pass yeah cuz
uh I got kicked out of school for they
said I was doing drugs and that footage
of me and my friends running around
campus in the other night and I was not
do any drugs and then we took me to our
family doctor and then so she that guy
just hired like outside laboratory I'm
not [ __ ] want to fail this
[ __ ] so I just peed I don't have
to watch me pee but I just peed into a
little cup and I filled the rest of it
up with water and I just tried to shake
it I put hot water this was warm and
I've been I passed it so there is like
tolerant THC levels so they don't test
for meth they took the test for the
active ingredient of everything and on
the report everything was like under my
moms like I want but you don't really
bad and that's nice not really bad I'm
like oh well she believes in me and I'm
a [ __ ] criminal yeah but what if you
bought car it would have been way worse
for you you would have felt I know back
that time I almost almost felt like I
just gotta come out about it but I can't
I got gangster values just kidding sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]